[Musica]
parliamo di nuove forme parliamo di
cambiamenti parliamo di trasformazioni
ma parliamo anche di certezze partiamo
anche con una parola un po se vogliamo
un po stizzosa inequivocabile siamo nel
2 milioni a 21 quindi dicembre 2021
viene pubblicato l'ultimo rapporto di un
panel di scienziati sì perché a questo
punto si dice che è inequivocabile che
le attività umane hanno riscaldato
l'atmosfera l'oceano e la terra ma non
lo diciamo soltanto nel 2021
partiamo da 30 anni fa un po più di
vent'anni fa siamo nel 1990 è una data
per chi studia questi questi temi
abbastanza storica esce il primo
rapporto sui cambiamenti climatici
due anni prima le nazioni unite e
l'organizzazione mondiale per la
meteorologia e decidono di mettere su di
creare un gruppo di scienziati che
potesse rastrellare tutta la produzione
scientifica a livello
internazionale e tirar fuori quello che
era il cosiddetto assessment quello che
era uno studio assolutamente autorevole
che mettesse le base potesse dare a
tutti i governi dei dati assolutamente
imperscrutabili
definiti scientificamente potessero
aiutarli a prendere le loro decisioni
bene nel 90 esce il primo rapporto e si
dice che le emissioni da attività umane
sostanzialmente hanno aumentato la
concentrazione di gas serra sì perché i
gas serra ci permettono di vivere su
questo pianeta senza gas serra naturali
noi avremo un pianeta un filino stile
con una temperatura di circa meno 18
gradi quindi ecco non potremmo vivere
sulla nostra amata terra però le
attività umane hanno
un impatto e stanno aumentando le
concentrazioni di questi gas e le
attività diciamo questo rapporto suscita
un certo dibattito crea
crea la possibilità di arrivare a delle
politiche internazionali quindi scienza
e politica iniziano a camminare insieme
e così nel 92 abbiamo il primo grande
trattato internazionale che si occupa
che la convenzione quadro sui
cambiamenti climatici finalmente i
governi decidono che bisogna fare
qualcosa ma si continua a pubblicare
quindi la produzione scientifica
continua ad andare avanti e nel 95 esce
il secondo rapporto e che cosa si dice
una delle frasi una delle frasi iniziale
che l'aumento delle concentrazioni di
gas serra può essere largamente
attribuito alle attività umane ma non è
abbastanza
aspettiamo il 2001 è io nel 2001 già mi
occupavo di questo tema in e si nel 2001
eravamo veramente molto entusiasti gli
scienziati che cosa scrivono nel terzo
rapporto che gran parte dell'aumento
della temperatura globale è
probabilmente dovuto all'aumento di
concentrazioni di gas serra compare
l'aumento della temperatura globale si
riconosce assolutamente scientificamente
provato la terra si sta scaldando e si
sta scaldando per colpa delle nostre
attività per colpa dell'attività
dell'uomo sul sul pianeta terra e voi mi
direte beh è abbastanza chiaro beh sì
abbastanza chiaro grazie al terzo
rapporto nasce di fatto il protocollo di
kyoto che viene di fatto entra in vigore
nel 2005 e poi sappiamo ha avuto diverse
vicissitudini ma gli scienziati
continuano a produrre letteratura
scientifica continuano a studiare il
fenomeno siamo nel 2007 esce il quarto
rapporto
e a questo punto cosa dicono dicono che
la gran parte dell'aumento della
temperatura
molto probabilmente dovuta all'aumento
di concentrazioni di gas serra quindi si
continua a rinforzare il concetto ma
evidentemente ancora non passa non passa
abbastanza non si fa abbastanza
in ogni caso la scienza continua arriva
il 2014 siamo tutti entusiasti
stiamo parlando del quinto rapporto
l'influenza umana sul clima è chiara più
chiaro di così beh in effetti questo
serve serve alla politica serve ai
governi internazionali durante una
conferenza durante la conferenza di
parigi nel 2015
finalmente esce l'accordo di parigi e
voi direte va bene quindi a questo punto
diciamo gli scienziati si sono dati pace
no perché siamo al sesto rapporto che è
stato pubblicato adesso l'ultimo volume
un mese fa e qui sinceramente non hanno
più parole da spendere qui gli
scienziati sono diciamo inequivocabili
l'attività umana è
inequivocabile che stia producendo stia
creando degli effetti è un impatto sul
riscaldamento del pianeta e vediamo
quindi di che cosa stiamo parlando
stiamo parlando
fondamentalmente di questo questo e
gallipoli 30 gennaio 2015 siamo siamo in
inverno e qui queste sono delle immagini
di un cosiddetto evento estremo una
mareggiata una mareggiata molto violente
cambiamenti climatici possono causare
questi fenomeni in modo che diventino
più frequenti quindi più eventi estremi
più frequentemente
possono accadere sulle nostre coste
stiamo parlando anche di piogge violenti
non solo di mareggiate
parliamo anche di siccità e di ondate di
calore ma come siamo arrivati a queste
conclusioni beh mi piacerebbe
farvi vedere un video che abbiamo
portato all'esposizione universale di
dubai che si è chiusa il 30 di marzo
questo è un video questi sono dei
modelli matematici che riescono a
riprodurre il sistema terra come
funziona la terra come come interagisce
l'atmosfera con gli oceani beh qui lo
vedete queste sono le nostre cose questa
e la puglia i modelli riesco ad andare a
un livello sempre più di dettaglio
questa è una simulazione delle corrente
questo e taranto il golfo di taranto e
malgrande il marp in golo potete vedere
che dettaglio riusciamo ad avere con con
i nostri modelli e questi modelli ci
aiutano a comprendere quello che potrà
accadere nel futuro e ci aiutano anche a
dare delle soluzioni e quindi la
modellistica climatica è il modo con il
quale gli scienziati fanno gli
esperimenti in laboratorio non possiamo
avere un laboratorio per lavorare con il
pianeta dobbiamo utilizzare la
modellistica climatica questa è un'altra
rappresentazione dei modelli che fanno i
modelli del nostro futuro adesso mi
rendo conto che di domenica sera insomma
questa slide è un filino pesante
fondamentalmente alla vostra sinistra
vedete delle rappresentazioni di quelli
che potrebbero essere dei percorsi
cosiddetti socio economici possibili c'è
una diverse forme di sviluppo che noi
potremmo intraprendere la linea in alto
viene chiamata percorso da pazzi ecco ma
perché da pazzi perché per ogni percorso
sono associate una quantità di emissioni
di gas effetto serra la co2 e altri gas
e che cosa significa lo vedete
dall'altra parte cioè significa
un riscaldamento un riscaldamento del
pianeta un livello di riscaldamento
diverso del pianeta il percorso da pazzi
ci porta ad avere al 2100 un
riscaldamento quasi pari a 5 gradi e
l'accordo di parigi cosa dice che
dobbiamo stare ben al di sotto i 2 gradi
perché perché oltre 2 gradi gli
scienziati non riescono effettivamente a
capire quali empatia quali impatti noi
potremmo andare incontro
e con quali scenario ne possiamo
arrivare a rispettare l'accordo di
parigi che sono gli scenari azzurri gli
scenari azzurra evidente ci chiedono di
diminuire le nostre emissioni di gas
effetto serra ma di diminuirle
abbastanza velocemente e quindi diciamo
che la modellistica climatica ci aiuta
anche a capire poi li potrebbero essere
impatti e la modellistica non è un
qualcosa che diciamo e sono questi
scienziati lontani che stanno che
lavorano su questi modelli beh diciamo
che qui in puglia siamo anche abbastanza
fortunati perché il nostro centro è a
lecce e quindi ci sono i miei colleghi
io non sono un modellista ma sono i miei
colleghi che che lavorano appunto allo
sviluppo di questi modelli
e questi sono quello che noi dovremmo
aspettarci per il sud italia quindi
anche per per la puglia per lecce per
per leverano di che parliamo parliamo di
sei giorni di ondate di calore in più
rispetto a quello che normalmente
chiamiamo così o quello che siamo
che abbiamo già sperimentato nel passato
un 2 per cento e meno di precipitazioni
annuali 18 notti cosiddette torride cioè
con la minima superiore ai 20 gradi e
poi vabbè addirittura 40 giorni caldi e
senza pioggia in più in un anno e se
immaginiamo un po quello che sono state
le nostre estati beh 40 giorni di caldo
in più ci fanno capire che forse forse
il problema in effetti c'è
e questi sono delle previsioni al 2050
quindi insomma in realtà non tanto
lontano 2050 ricordate il 1990 insomma
più o meno stiamo parlando dello stesso
orizzonte temporale indietro e in avanti
e quindi dobbiamo decidere in che mondo
che mondo che forma vuole vogliamo che
il nostro mondo prenda l'abbiamo visto
che su che linea vogliamo vogliamo
andare su che linea vogliamo vogliamo
viaggiare in realtà l'europa un po ha
deciso cioè noi europei abbiamo deciso
che vogliamo diventare il primo
continente climaticamente neutrale al
2050 che cosa vuol dire che tutte le
nostre missioni dobbiamo fare in modo
che il nostro sistema terra la nostra
natura sia in grado di assorbire quello
che non riesce assorbire la natura le
foreste l'oceano dobbiamo cercare di
chiaramente ridurli oppure di usare
anche delle tecnologie perché esistono
anche delle tecnologie più o meno con
diverse fasi di sviluppo per poter
assorbire queste queste missioni c'è una
legge c'è una legge a livello europeo
che lo richiede e c'è anche un obiettivo
intermedio meno 55 per cento al
2030 2030 siamo nel 2022 otto anni meno
55 per cento questa cosa avrà un impatto
su di noi
e queste sono delle frasi che non vi
leggo sono le frasi estrapolate da
questo sesto rapporto e che cosa dicono
dicono che l'azione deve essere
immediata noi abbiamo tempo fino al 2025
dopo il 2025 gioco forza dobbiamo
scendere dobbiamo scendere con le nostre
emissioni e questo lo possiamo fare con
il rafforzamento delle politiche
climatiche chiaramente la scienza sta
continuando a lavorare per dare dati per
poter fornire informazioni
scientificamente
rilevanti ai nostri decisori
quindi è questo quello che deve essere
il nostro impegno nel futuro e quello
per il quale per il quale noi siamo
lavorando quindi in realtà non si può
kabir golette tornare indietro per
quello parlavo di certezze non possiamo
tornare indietro in realtà le politiche
a livello internazionale le abbiamo
viste ci sono ma ci sono anche anche a
livello locale in italia c'è una
strategia di sviluppo sostenibile se
arriveremo fra pochissimo alla seconda
edizione e per più del 60 per cento dei
comuni italiani aderiscono al patto dei
sindaci per il clima e l'energia
significa che questi comuni decidono di
di darsi degli obiettivi proprio in in
ottemperanza a quelli che sono gli
accordi che abbiamo visto prima quindi
l'accordo di parigi e allora e allora
noi che cosa possiamo fare bene le
soluzioni ci sono questa è la bella e la
buona notizia le soluzioni ci sono non
vi dirò di andarvi a leggere il sesto
rapporto che però per ogni settore
colpito definisce da delle possibili
soluzioni ci sono già delle buone
notizie abbiamo il costo di produzione
dell'energia rinnovabile lo vedete da
quei grafici quelle curve scendono
perché sono scese dal 2000 al 2020 i
costi di riproduzione quindi ce la
possiamo fare però in realtà dobbiamo
iniziare immaginare un nuovo mondo
dobbiamo iniziare a immaginare un nuovo
mondo di stare su questa terra
un modo mondo nel quale noi ci occupiamo
anche della natura dove la natura inizia
ad avere un ruolo non solo come diciamo
essere depredato dall'uomo che insiste e
si sente superiore a tutto ma la natura
può anche aiutarci con delle soluzioni
che noi chiamiamo tecnologie verdi per
esempio le dune delle spiagge sono
fondamentali per poter frenare fenomeni
dell'erosione costiera ma ci sono
addirittura degli studi e dei miei
colleghi hanno messo stanno creando dei
modelli per dimostrare come delle
foreste di poseidonia siano in grado di
contrastare la violenza del mare come
quella che abbiamo visto prima a
gallipoli è però possiamo anche
immaginare le nostre città come dei
luoghi dove effettivamente si possa fare
qualcosa insieme sì perché la comunità
la partecipazione la natura sono le
parole chiave di questo di questo
cambiamento e quindi all'interno delle
città dove la maggior parte delle
persone vivono sul pianeta e lì e nelle
città dove dobbiamo anche trovare le
soluzioni e poi ci sono anche le nostre
abitudini le nostre la nostra dieta che
può essere che può essere
modificata
pensiamo alla follia di utilizzare un
materiale che è stato inventato per per
non distruggersi mai per usarlo soltanto
una volta per bere un bicchier d'acqua
dobbiamo assolutamente cambiare dobbiamo
cambiare noi stessi per immaginare un
nuovo futuro
e a me piace molto pensare che questa in
realtà sarà è la prima generazione che
potrà agire concretamente per il
cambiamento climatico
la mia generazione ha creduto
immediatamente a quel messaggio che fu
dato dagli scienziati nel 1990 ha
continuato a interessarsi dell'argomento
a studiarlo a far sì che i decisori
potessero prendere i messaggi importanti
e tradurle in politiche ma questa sarà
la generazione che potrà
concretamente fare qualcosa è un
sicuramente un onere però anche un
grande onore per per la generazione dei
giovani di adesso e lo vediamo da queste
da queste immagini non c'è da dire è
molto e quindi è quindi vorrei
semplicemente salutarvi con questa
certezza il cambiamento verso un futuro
sostenibile ci sarà
quanto sarà veloce ma questo dipende da
tutti noi grazie
[Applauso]